foreign
[Music]
's really working it's just getting
worse I see more and more people out on
the streets every day so I'll just ask
you this how long have you been homeless
in Portland
yours has anyone helped you get off the
streets any Outreach workers no
since 2013
um this is the first time
somebody spoke to me came out and spoke
to me like this
any really permanent Solutions being
offered to anybody uh the most that I've
seen is just you know like here let me
give you a really thin blanket you know
let me give you a 10.
[Music]
welfare check everything okay
all right cool thank you my name is
Kevin Dahlgren and I've worked in Social
Services for over 27 years primarily in
Portland Oregon I'm a drug and alcohol
counselor and the last several years
I've been really focused on trying to be
a truth teller and to really talk about
this dysfunctional system
to find ways to improve it
the work was easier back in the day we
had some you know there was some good
programs some still exist here but what
I saw over time is what once was this
cause really became this multi-million
dollar industry we went from a couple
shelters to dozens of shelters we went
from a uh just a couple Outreach teams
to dozens of Outreach teams yet the
crisis continued to grow over here and
pretty quickly I was realizing like I
feel like we're part of the problem
like we're here to serve them and help
them and make them you know meet the
recovery goals yet the problem continued
to grow every year and so more and more
things shifted from permanent solutions
to Band-Aid approaches
this is an empty tent erected my
activists to approach
so back in the day when we did Outreach
our Focus was what's the permanent
solution how are we going to help them
today get them off the streets solve the
problem you know move on to the next
person and then eventually just became
here's another tent here's another tarp
here's another peanut butter sandwich
and so of course when you're not
actually helping the permanent Solutions
the old homeless stay there and the new
homeless come in and everything just
grows
and I don't know exactly why except I
think there was certainly a shift in
Portland politics in people ideologies
just sort of changed over the last 20
years
1312 stands for all cops are bastards
right black lives matter and kill a bomb
so you see this is a pretty divided City
if money were the solution we would have
already solved it you've almost never
see Outreach workers out here and if you
do they're there for the wrong reasons
they're there for maybe harm reduction
like here's another needle here's more
tin foil what we now see is an open-air
drug scene go to almost any Block in
downtown Portland in most other areas in
Portland and you're going to see people
using the fentanyl holding the foil
lighting it with the straw usually with
you know a blanket over their head so
you know they none of the smoke escapes
it right in front of you
in public parks and you know you walk
downtown Portland uh Seattle San
Francisco you see just tin foil
scattered everywhere because that's
completely replaced heroin
so I mean like the fetty problem is a
huge issue out here so
I mean
I'm sure you'll see if you walk around
long enough you'll see people slumped
over people just like standing in the
middle of the sidewalk just slumped over
with their stuff all sprawled out over
the floor so and then you know like
everyone so you desensitize to it so
like it's just normal do their drug
front in front of cops and cops don't do
anything which I mean that's good that
the cops aren't ruining their lives even
more the amount of lives that I've saved
with the Narcan is amazing I mean I've
saved like 20 people over the last like
since I've been using it so we know what
to do when somebody's oding I would
argue you know we asked where the
Outreach workers are the homeless have
become the Outreach workers helping
people right that's what's going on you
have probably done more good helping
people than actual paid Outreach workers
saving people I'm the first Outreach
worker to talk to him in nine years in
Portland Oregon I hear this every day so
where are they it's not like this is an
issue where well he's not easy to
approach he was there very personable
wanting to talk about the system
thank you
it's about 80 percent of the homeless
have a history of addiction and of that
80 percent you know most of them are
addicted to fentanyl now and the reason
why is even if there are drug of choices
like meth marijuana
or something else the new thing is that
fentanyl powder is sprinkled on other
all the other drugs because it's cheap
and it's highly addictive and that's
actually that's why we've seen an
increase in overdoses and deaths is
unsuspecting people who may have no
interest in fentanyl buy something else
on the streets and there was fentanyl in
it
is highly addictive and it wears off
within about one and a half to two hours
so what that has created is this
desperation I've been interviewing the
homeless the last year who have been on
Fentanyl and they said look
the moment I wake up my first thought is
how am I going to get enough pills to
get through the day right and on average
you know a
heavy fentanyl user needs about 15 pills
or so right 10 to 15 and that's their
number one goal in the world so if
they're out of money or don't have like
say a side hustle that creates a
desperation because their number one
goal is I need to get the pills so I
don't go through detox
because that's terrifying to them so
that's where the crime happens is with
desperation you're going to see an
increase in crime is we see a lot of
Smash and grabs in Portland and Seattle
that means you're breaking into the wind
of a car and pulling out whatever you
see you know men and women now more than
I've ever seen before starting to sell
their bodies uh for one to two pills
you know like steal from stores you know
like I try to keep everything like legal
and the best I can you know
I personally just Panhandle there's a
lot
like they have no qualms about it like
they don't care like they're they're not
gonna get sick and it's kind of their
their motto with it
breaking into a car and stealing your
cell phone or you know like just playing
blatantly robbing you on the street you
know they'll do it
me and my girl we left
to go to we hop on the max to go to the
other side of town and when we came back
everything we owned was gone
so we're never there I think they took
everything
and it's just like that and it's the
homeless Stone from homeless it's really
sad it's very sad
I think it really is just comes down to
ideologies is you know there's the harm
reduction model which you know you're
trying to prevent death
therefore let's give you a new needle
let's give you let's give you the means
to continue to use but we're hoping you
don't die from it right I don't I'm a
drug and all counselor and I don't
support harm reduction because it ends
up actually hurting people and I help
them in harm reduction it's all harm and
no reduction because even they admit we
don't have nine times out of ten they
won't even offer the sobriety solution
or the Recovery Solution it's more of
like here's the means to continue to use
and that's very frustrating for me
you're given a person who already lacks
critical thinking and rational thought
the means to continue to use and that's
insane to me and it feels at times
really inhumane
how often I've been building more detox
facilities and so again my uh colleagues
with a different
ideology
thinks that this is an affordable
housing issue so let's put ninety
percent of money towards that I'm saying
look let's actually switch those two
ninety percent of the resources needs to
go towards the detox and the Outreach
because that's step one if you don't get
through step one it doesn't matter what
step 10 is they will never reach that
goal
foreign
you know I see so much potential in
everybody on the streets about where
what if they could just meet me halfway
if I could somehow work them through
their ambivalence and give them hope
again and build that trust they can
recover and become self-sufficient and
just Thrive because that should be the
number one goal with homeless Outreach
is how do we make them self-sufficient
how do we make them thrive
foreign